you have been a proponent of Ubi
Universal basic income in the context of
AI can you describe your philosophy
there of of our human future with Ubi
why why you like it what are some
limitations I think it is a component
of something we should pursue it is not
a full solution I think people work for
lots of reasons besides money
um
and I think we are going to find
incredible new jobs and society as a
whole and people's individuals are going
to get much much richer but as a cushion
through a dramatic transition and it's
just like
you know I think the world should
eliminate poverty if able to do so I
think it's a great thing to do
um as a small part of the bucket of
solutions I helped start a project
called World coin
um
which is a technological solution to
this we also have funded a uh like a
large I think maybe the the largest and
most comprehensive Universal basic
income study
as part of sponsored by open AI
and I think it's like an area we should
just be be looking into
what are some like insights from that
study that you gain we're going to
finish up at the end of this year and
we'll be able to talk about it hopefully
early very early next